looking up at the night sky we are
amazed by how it seems to go on forever
but what will the sky look like billions
of years from now a particular type of
scientist called a cosmologists spends
her time thinking about that very
question the end of the universe is
intimately linked to what the universe
contains over 100 years ago
Einstein developed the theory of general
relativity formed of equations that help
us understand the relationship between
what a universe is made of and its shape
it turns out that the universe could be
curved like a ball or sphere we call
this positively curved or closed or it
could be shaped like a saddle we call
this negatively curved or open or it
could be flat and that shape determines
how the universe will live and die we
now know that the universe is very close
to flat however the components of the
universe can still affect its eventual
fate we can predict how the universe
will change with time if we measure the
amounts or energy densities of the
various components in the universe today
so what is the universe made of the
universe contains all the things that we
can see like stars gas and planets we
call these things ordinary or baryonic
matter even though we see them all
around us the total energy density of
these components is actually very small
around 5% of the total energy of the
universe so now let's talk about what
the other 95% is just under 27% of the
rest of the energy density of the
universe is made up of what we call dark
matter dark matter is only very weakly
interacting with light which means it
doesn't shine or reflect light in the
way that stars and planets do but in
every other way it behaves like ordinary
matter it attract things gravitationally
in fact the only way we can detect this
dark matter is through this
gravitational interaction how things
orbit around it and how it bends light
as it curves the space around it we have
yet to discover the dark matter particle
but scientists all over the world are
searching for this elusive particle or
particles and the effects of dark matter
on the universe
but the still doesn't add up to 100% the
remaining 68% of the energy density of
the universe is made up of dark energy
which is even more mysterious than dark
matter this dark energy doesn't behave
like any other substance we know at all
and acts more like anti-gravity force we
say that it has a gravitational pressure
which ordinary matter and dark matter do
not instead of pulling the universe
together as we would expect gravity to
do the universe appears to be expanding
apart at an ever-increasing rate the
leading idea for dark energy is that it
is a cosmological constant that means it
has the strange property that it expands
as the volume of space increases to keep
its energy density constant so as the
universe expands as it is doing right
now there will be more and more dark
energy dark matter and baryonic matter
on the other hand don't expand with the
universe and become more diluted because
of this property of the cosmological
constant the future universe will be
more and more dominated by dark energy
becoming colder and colder and expanding
faster and faster eventually the
universe will run out of gas to form
stars and the stars themselves will run
out of fuel and burn out leaving the
universe with only black holes in it
given enough time even these black holes
will evaporate leaving a universe that
is completely cold and empty that is
what we call the heat death of the
universe while it might sound depressing
living in a universe that will end its
lifetime cold and devoid of life the end
fate of our universe actually has a
beautiful symmetry to its hot fiery
beginning we call the accelerating end
state of the universe a desert a phase
named after the dutch mathematician
willem de sitter however we also believe
that the universe had another phase of
dissertate expansion in the earliest
times of its life we call this early
period inflation where shortly after the
Big Bang the universe expanded extremely
fast for a brief period so the universe
will end in much the same state as it
began
accelerating we live at an extraordinary
time in the life of the universe where
we can start to understand the
universe's journey and view a history
that plays itself out on the sky for all
of us to see